if you're not playing rocket League this
week for some reason here's all the
games that are coming out Ubisoft takes
us back to the Stone Age with Far Cry
primal and you get to tango with all
sorts of crazy beasts from the
mesolithic period like mammoths and
saber-toothed Wildcats care sig by two
cars and guns and hello to spears clubs
axes and good old-fashioned foes you
gotta hunt for food and learn to create
fire besides facing natural predators
like honey badgers players also get the
chance to be the leader of a tribe and
protect their tribe from other tribes by
killing them possibly with bees that's
out on the twenty-third turn-based
strategy game hitman go is releasing the
definitive version this week originally
a critically acclaimed game for mobile
this revisited edition of hitman go
features all the original games content
upgrades which adds up to about 91
turn-based puzzles for your ps4 or Vita
get to the important stuff you say the
game has platinum trophy yes and game
will be crossed by and cross save yes
yes you will be able to play any way you
want from dual shock for analog stick or
touchpad to the PS vita's front touch
screen or on a plane or train or even in
the rain rain isn't recommended it also
looks nice that's out on the
twenty-third if you like plants vs
zombies garden warfare you should
probably consider the sequel plants vs
zombies garden warfare 2 why do they
even have the garden warfare part if
you're just gonna add 2 on it for the
sequel you're missing a golden
opportunity for more plant puns why not
make it plants vs zombies brain harvest
or plants vs zombies seeds of
destruction or plants vs zombies dirt
nap I could go on EA those three are
free game adds 60 plant and zombie
classes a zombie version of garden ops
titled graveyard ops and a new mode
called herbal assault mode which
supports 24 players you can also play
every mode now solo that's out on the
twenty-third well
this week telltale keeps us wanting more
walking dead by giving us a miniseries
based on the most beloved character no
not you Carl you dumb [ __ ] it's me shown
the blade wielding character from Robert
Kirkman's best selling comic books and
she's portrayed in game by Ward winning
actress sameera Wiley who you might
remember from Orange is the new black
haunted by her past and coping with
unimaginable loss and regret the story
explores me shown across three episodes
you get to wield the blade on the
twenty-third oh but keep some of that
money in your pockets because we also
get the flame in the flood from an
incredible group of developers who
previously works on bioshock infinite so
you know it's a good pedigree this game
is gorgeous and the audio is soothing
and calming and you're going to need
that because you're out in the woods
surviving but crafts and clothing and
weapons to kill wolves and upgrading
rafts so you can forge it on a river
full of Rapids you can find out what
happened to your family and friends you
can be safe and warm if you like
survival games I think this is an easy
win also you get a pet dog that follows
you around no you can't eat him that's
the 24 disgaea fans will be happy to
hear their beloved role-playing game is
coming to PC this week but it ain't the
newest one you're getting PlayStation
choose disgaea hour of darkness the
version coming to steam includes all the
added content of afternoon of darkness
rerelease and if this guide as well you
can expect more in the series to make
the jump as well that's out on the 24th
finally stop and think wait no punch
that guy in the face it's super hot a
super good looking shooter where time
only moves when you do so it gives you
time to really stop and holy [ __ ] that's
a truck you'd think it'd be more
relaxing but your heart gets racing even
when I dudes shooting slow bullets but
then you get that sweet matrix move when
you like dodge it just right yeah this
game is sweet that's out on the 25th so
that's all the games you should know
about this week remember that sometimes
release dates change so be sure to stay
tuned to gamespot so we can let you know
if that happened we also have a bunch of
Far Cry primal gameplay up on the site
so you can check that out if you want to
try before you buy and I'll see you guys
again next week
Oh